some program is sponsored by the Republican
National Committee the Republican Senatorial
Campaign Committee and the Republican
Congressional Committee you are about to
hear a report from Senator Richard Nixon nominee
for the office of vice-president the United States
the senator is interrupted his nationwide campaign
tour to be with you tonight his important message
ladies and gentlemen Senator Richard Nixon my
fellow Americans I come before you tonight as
a candidate for the vice president and as a man
whose honesty and integrity has been questioned a
usual political thing to do when charges are made
against you is to either ignore them or to deny
them without giving details I believe we've had
enough of that in the United States particularly
with the president ministration in Washington
DC to me the office of the vice presidency of
the United States is a great office and I feel
that the people have got to have confidence in
the integrity of the men who run for that office
and who might obtain I have a theory too but the
best and only answers to a smear or to an honest
misunderstanding of the faculty is to tell the
truth and that's why I'm here tonight I want to
tell you my side of the case I'm sure that you
have read the charge and you've heard it but I
Senator Nixon took $18,000 from the group but my
support now was that wrong the question is was it
morally wrong I'd say that it was morally wrong if
any of that 18,000 dollars went to senator Nixon
for my personal use I say that it was morally
wrong if it was secretly given and secretly
him and I say that it was morally wrong if
any of the contributors got special favors for the
contributions that they meant it was not a secret
as a matter of fact when I was on Meet the Press
some of you may have seen it last Sunday Peter
Edson came up to me after the program and he
said dick what about this fund we hear about
and I said well there's no secret about it go
out and see Dana Smith who was the administrator
of the [ __ ] and I gave him his address and I
said you will find that the purpose of the fund
simply was to defray political expenses that I did
not feel should be charged to the government and
third let me point out and I want to make this
particularly quick that no contributor to this
fund no contributor to any of my campaign has
ever received any consideration that he would
not have received as an ordinary constituent I
just don't believe in it and I can say that never
while I have been in the Senate of the United
States as far as the people that contributed
to this fund of concern have I made a telephone
call for them to an agency or have I gone down to
an agency and their behalf and the records will
show that the records which are in the hand of
the administration well then some of you will
say and rightly well what did you use the fund
for some why did you have to have let me tell you
in just a word how a Senate office operates first
of all the senator gets $15,000 a year in salary
he gets enough money to pay for one trip a year
a round trip that is for himself and his family
between his home Washington DC and then he gets
an allowance to handle the people that work in his
own to handle his mail and the allowance for my
state of California is enough to hire 13 people
and let me say incidentally that that allowance
is not paid to the Senate it's paid directly to
the individuals that the senator what's on it
field but all of these people and all of these
allowances are for strictly official business
business for example when a constituent right
then and want you to go down to the Veterans
Administration and get some information about his
GI power items of that time for example but there
are other expenses which are not covered by the
government and I think I can best discuss those
expenses by asking you some questions do you think
that when I or any other senator makes a political
speech has it printed should charge the printing
of that speech and the mailing of that speech to
the taxpayers do you think for example when I or
any other senator makes a trip to his home state
to make a purely political speech that the cost
of that print should be charged to the taxpayer
do you think when a senator makes political
broadcast or political television broadcast radio
or television at the expense of those broadcast
should be charged to the taxpayer I know what
your answer is the same answer that audiences give
me whenever I discuss this particular problem the
answer is no the taxpayers shouldn't be required
to finance items which are not official business
but which are primarily political well then the
question arises you say well how do you pay for
these and how can you do it legally and there are
several ways that it can be done incidentally and
that it is done legally in the United States
Senate and the Congress first way is to be a
rich man I don't happen to be a rich man so I
couldn't use another way that is use is to put
your wife on the pig let me say incidentally
this my opponent my opposite number for the
vice presidency of the Democratic ticket does have
his wife on the payroll and has had it her on his
payroll for the ten years for the past ten years
I just let me say this that's his business and I'm
not critical of him for doing that you will have
to pass judgment on that particular point but I
have never done that for this reason I have found
that there are so many deserving stenographers
and secretaries in Washington that needed the
work but I just didn't feel it was right to put
my wife in the payroll my wife sitting over here
she's a wonderful stenographer she used to teach
stenography and to use to teach shorthand in high
school proud to stay tonight and in the six years
I've been in the House Senate of the United
States APNIC has never been on the government
paper what are other ways these finances can be
taken care of some who are lawyers and I happen
to be a lawyer continue to practice law but I
haven't been able to do that I'm so far away
from California that I've been too busy with my
senatorial works that I have not engaged in any
legal practice and also as far as law practice was
concerned it seemed to me that the relationship
between an attorney and the client was so personal
that you couldn't possibly represent a man as an
attorney and then have an unbiased view when he
presented his case to you in the event that he
had one and so I felt that the best way to handle
these necessary political expenses of getting my
message to the American people and the speeches I
made the speeches that I had printed for the most
part concerned this one measure of exposing this
administration the communism in the corruption
is the only way that I could do that was to accept
the egg-wich people in my home state of California
who contributed to my campaign and who continued
otherwise have never paid one guy for expenses
which I thought were political and shouldn't be
charged to detect let me say incidentally that
some of you may say well that's all right senator
that's your explanation but have you got any proof
and I'd like to tell you this evening that just an
hour ago we receive an independent audit of this
entire fund I suggested to Governor Sherman
Adams who was the chief of staff of the dry
ties narcan pain that an independent audit and
legal report be obtained and I have that audit
here in my hand it's an audit made by the Price
Waterhouse & Company firm and the legal opinion
by Gibson Dunn & Crutcher lawyers in Los Angeles
the biggest law firm and incidentally one of the
best ones in Los Angeles I'm proud to be able to
report to you tonight if this audit and this legal
opinion is being forwarded generalized eyes now
and I'd like to read to you the opinion that was
prepared by Gibson Dunn & Crutcher and based on
all the pertinent laws and statutes together with
the audit report prepared by the certified public
accountant well it is our conclusion that senator
Nixon did not obtain any financial gain from
the collection and disbursement of the fund by
Dana Smith that Senator Nixon did not violate any
federal or state law by reason of the operation of
the fund and that neither the portion of the fund
paid by Dana Smith directly the third person nor
the portion paid to senator Nixon to reimburse
him for designated office expenses constituted
income to the senator which was either reportable
or taxable as income under applicable tax law
signed Gibson Dunn and Crutcher by Elmo H con now
that my friends is not Nixon speaking but that's
an independent audit which was requested because
I want the American people to know all the facts
and I'm not afraid of having independent people
go in and check the tax and that is exactly what
they did how can we believe what you say after
all is there a possibility that maybe you got
some sums in cash is there a possibility that
you may have feather your own nest and so now
what I am going to do and incidentally this is
unprecedented in the history of American party I
am going at this time give to this television and
radio audit audience a complete financial history
everything I've earned everything I've spent
everything I all want you to know that I'll have
to start early I was born in 1913 our family was
one of modest circumstances and most of my early
life was spent in a store out in Eastwood it was
a grocery store one of those family enterprises
the only reason we were able to make it go was
because my mother and dad had five boys and we
all worked in the store I worked my way through
college and to a great extent through law school
and then in 1940 probably the best thing that
ever happened to me happened I married Pat I'm
sitting over here we had a rather difficult time
after we were married like so many of the young
couples who may be listening Joyce I practice law
she continued to teach school then in 1942 I went
into the service let me say that my service record
was not a particularly unusual one I went to the
South Pacific I guess I'm entitled to a couple
of Battlestars I got a couple of letters of
commendation but I was just there when the bombs
were falling and then I returned returned to the
United States and in 1946 I ran for the country
when we came out of the war Pat and I Pat during
the war had worked as a stenographer and in a
bank and as an economist for a government agent
and when we came out the total of our savings
from both my law practice her teaching and all
the time that I was in the war the total for that
entire period was just a little less than $10,000
every set of attitude Emily was in government
Bob well that's where we start when I go into
politics now what have I earned since I went
into politics well here it is I've jotted it
down let me read the notes first of all I've had
my salary and second I have received a total in
this past six years of $1600 from a state which
were in my law firm at the time that I severed my
connection with and incidentally as I said before
I have not engaged in any legal practice and have
not accepted any fees from business that came
into the firm after I went into all I have made
an average of approximately $1,500 a year from
non-political speaking engagements and lectures
unfortunately we've inherited a little money
at sold her interest and her father's estate
we lived rather modest for four years we live at
San via Virginia the rent was $30 a month and we
saved for the time that we could buy a house now
it was surprised because it is so little I suppose
as standards generally go of people in public life
first of all we've got a house in Washington which
caused forty one thousand dollars and in which we
owe $20,000 we have a house in Whittier California
which costs thirteen thousand dollars and on
which we all $3,000 my folks are living there
at the present time I have just four thousand
dollars in life insurance plus my GI policy which
I've never been able to convert and which will
run out in two years I have no life insurance
whatever run pack I have no life insurance on our
two youngsters Trisha I own a 1950 Oldsmobile car
we have our furniture we have no stocks and
bonds of any time we have no interest of any
kind director in the indirect in any business
now that's what we have what are we oh well in
addition to the mortgage the twenty thousand
dollar mortgage on the house in Washington the
ten thousand dollar one on the house and Whittier
I owe $4,500 to the Riggs Bank in Washington with
interest four-and-a-half percent I owe $3,500 to
my parents and the interest on that loan which
I pay regularly because it's the part of the
savings they made through the years they were
working so hard I pay regularly four percent and
then I have a $500 loan which I have on my life
that's what we have it isn't very much but Pat
and I have the satisfaction it every dime that
we've got is honest to god I should say this that
Pat doesn't have a mink coat but she does have a
respectable Republican cloth coat and I always
tell her that she'd look good in anything one
other thing I probably should tell you because if
I don't they'll probably be saying this about me
too we did get something you'll give after the
election a man down in Texas heard Pat in the
radio mentioned the fact that our two youngsters
would like to have a dog and believe it or not
the day before we left from his campaign trip we
got a message from Union Station Baltimore saying
they had a package for they went down to get
it you know what it was it was a little cocker
spaniel dog in a crate that he sent all the way
from Texas black-and-white spotted and our little
girl Trisha the six year old named it check you
know the kids like all kids love the dog and I
just want to say this right now that regardless
of what they say about it we're going to keep
it isn't easy to come before a nationwide audience
and there your life as I've done and I want to say
some things before I conclude first of all you
have written the papers about other fund now
mr. Stevenson apparently had a company one
of them in which a group of business people
paid and helped to supplement the salaries of
state employees here is where the money went
directly into their pockets and I think what
mr. Stevenson to do should be to come before
the American people are dying give the names of
the people that contributed to that fund give
the names of the people who put this money into
their pockets at the same time that they were
receiving money from their state government and
see what favors if any they gave out for them I
don't condemn mr. Stevenson for what he did
but until the facts are in there is a doubt
that we'll be ready and as far as mr. Sparkman
is concerned I would suggest the same thing he's
had his wife in the payroll I don't condemn him
for that but I think that he should come before
the American people and indicate what outside
sources of income he attacked I would suggest
that under the circumstances both mr. Sparkman and
mr. Stevens should come before the American people
as I have and make complete financial statement
as to their financial history and if they don't
it will be an admission that they have something
to hide and I think you will agree because folks
remember a man that's to be President of the
United States a man that's to be vice president
of the United States must have the confidence of
all the people and that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing and that's why I suggest that mr. Stevenson
and mr. Sparkman since they are under attack
to do what they're doing now let me say this I
know that this is not the last of this marriage
in spite of my explanation tonight other smears
will be made others have been made in the past
and the purpose of the smears I know is this
to silence me to make me let up well they just
don't know who they're dealing with I'm going
to tell you this I remember in the dark days of
the history some of the same colonists some of
the same radio commentators who are attacking
me now and misrepresenting my position we're
violently opposing me at the time I was after
our hit but I continued to fight because I knew I
was right and I can say to this great television
and radio audience that I have no apologies to
the American people for my part in putting out
your his where he is yeah and as far as this is
concerned I intend to continue to fund why do
I feel so thinking why do I feel that in spite of
the smears the misunderstanding the necessity for
a man to come up here and bare as soul as I have
why is it necessary for me to continue this fight
I want to tell you why because you see I love
my country and I think my country is in danger
and I think the only man that can save America at
this time is the man that's running for president
on my ticket bright eyes now you say why I think
it's in danger and I say look at the record seven
years of the Truman Atchison Administration of
what's happened six hundred million people lost
to the Communists and a war in Korea in which
we have lost a hundred and seventeen thousand
American casualties and I say to all of you that
a policy that results in the loss of 600 million
people at the Communists and a war which cost
us a hundred and seventeen thousand American
casualties isn't good enough for America and I
say that those in the state part that made the
mistakes which caused that war and which resulted
in those losses should be kicked out of the State
Department just as fast as we get em out of it
and let me say that I know mr. Stevenson won't
do that because he defends the Truman policy and
I know that flight eisenhower will do that and
that he will give America the leadership that
it means take the problem of corruption you
read about the mess in Washington mr. Stevenson
can't clean it up because he was picked for the
man Truman under whose administration the mess
was made you wouldn't trust the man who made
the mess to clean it up that's Truman and by
the same token you can't trust the man who was
picked for the man that made the mess to clean
it up and that's Steven and so I say Eisenhower
who owed nothing to Truman nothing to the big city
bosses he is the man that can clean up the mess in
Washington take communism I'd say that as far as
that subject is concerned the danger is great to
America in the his case they got two secrets which
enabled them to break the American secret State
Department code they got secrets in the atomic
bomb case which enabled him to get the secret of
the atomic bomb five years before they would have
gotten it by their own device and I say that any
man who called the Alger Hiss case a red herring
isn't fit to be President of the United States I
say that a man who like mr. Stevenson is proof
food and ridiculed the communist threat in the
United States he said that they are phantoms among
ourselves he's accused us that have attempted to
expose the Communists of looking for communists in
the Bureau of fisheries file life I say that a man
who says that isn't qualified to be President of
the United States and I say that the only man who
can lead us in this fight to rid the government
of both those who are communists and those who
have corrupted this government is Eisenhower
because Eisenhower you can be sure recognizes
the problem and he knows how do your weapon now
let me say this final decision I want to read
you just briefly excerpts from a letter which I
received a letter which after all this is over no
one can take away it reads as follows dear senator
nips since I'm only 19 years of age I can't vote
in this presidential election but believe me if I
could you and General Eisenhower would certainly
get my vote my husband is in the fleet Marines
in Korea he's the Karman on the frontlines and
we have a two month old son he's never seen and I
feel confident that with great Americans like you
and General Eisenhower in the White House lonely
Americans like myself will be united with their
loved ones now in Korea I only pray to God that
you won't be too late enclosed is a small check
to help you in your campaign living on $85 a month
it is all I can afford at present but let me know
what else I can do folks at the check for $10 and
it's one that I will never catch and just let me
say this we hear a lot about prosperity these days
but I say why can't we have prosperity built on
peace rather than prosperity built on well war why
can't we have prosperity and an honest government
in Washington DC at the same time believe me we
can and Eisenhower is the man that can lead this
crusade to bring us that's kind of possible now
finally I know that you wonder whether or not I am
going to stay on the Republican ticket or resign
let me say this I don't believe that I ought
to quit because I am NOT a quitter and Method
Emily Pat's not a quitter after all her name was
Patricia Ryan and she was born a Patrick's Day and
you know the Irish never quit but the decision my
friends is not mine I would do nothing that would
harm the possibilities of Dwight Eisenhower to
become president of the United States and for that
reason I am submitting to the Republican National
Committee tonight through this television
broadcast the decision which it is theirs
to make let them decide whether my position on the
ticket will help her her and I'm going to ask you
to help them decide wire and write the Republican
National Committee whether you think I should stay
or whether I should get off just let me say this
last word regardless of what happens I'm going
to continue this fight I'm going to campaign up
and down in America until we drive the trucks
in the communists and those that defend them out
of Washington and remember folks Eisenhower is a
great man believe he's a great man and they're
both for eisenhower is a vote for what's good
for a merry publican Senatorial Committee
and the Republican Congressional Committee